you
[Music]
hi my name is Mel Gregory and I am a
software engineer at our studio and I
work on the team that's building our
studio cloud which we've heard about a
little bit today um and this one I'm
here to talk to you about so this talk
is primarily geared toward people who
are teaching data science or statistics
or anything else where your students
might want to do some data analysis and
to that end I'm gonna briefly detail a
little bit about how our studio cloud
works for anyone who hasn't yet seen it
and I will spend the rest of my time
today demonstrating why and how to use
our studio cloud on a teaching context
how it can make teaching a class a
course or a workshop easier and along
the way I will highlight a few best
practices for doing this I will also
talk about some current limitations and
touching a few additional learning
resources that are Studio cloud makes
available namely drivers ok so let's
imagine that I'm teaching and intro to
data science class for our purposes here
my students will be doing data analysis
using our but probably don't have a ton
of prior experience writing code so to
get started they might do something like
this maybe on maybe ahead of time but
probably on the first day install our
install our studio
maybe install some packages cool and
then they're gonna troubleshoot some
installation problems and I might just
have to help here and then finally they
get here
and you know that's that's a lot to do
before writing any code and it can be
tricky especially if you're new to this
and given the myriad different systems
that my students might bring with them
it's actually a lot for me to
potentially troubleshoot to if things go
sideways so on the other hand the first
date could be this go to our studio
cloud and your web browser login or sign
up create a new project and you're there
so there's no installation here and
there's no setup for students to do
aside from signing up for an account and
when using our studio cloud students
will all be running the same versions of
our and the r studio ide automatically
so there's no installation
troubleshooting to do there either
additionally with a little bit of prayer
set up on the instructor side students
will also have the same versions of the
same packages installed included already
so now this is not to say that students
shouldn't have to know how to do all
this stuff they should understanding how
the various pieces fit together is
really important but it's a lot to
understand up front and maybe it's not
the most important thing to learn first
getting up and running quickly provides
an invaluable sense of progress here and
we can come back to these details when
they have
a bit more context so our studio cloud
briefly our studio cloud is er Studio
IDE available as a service that you can
access from anywhere you have an
internet connection and a modern web
browser it doesn't require any IT
support or local installation and you
can send it for an account and you can
use it today we created our Studio cloud
to make it easy to do share teach and
learn data science using our and in
support of that mission we've built a
ton of extra features to make it easier
to organize work teach classes learn our
on share analyses so first a little bit
of basic terminology in our studio cloud
the fundamental unit of work is a
project it encapsulates your our code
packages and data files and provides
isolation from other analyses so this is
analogous to projects in a local
installation of the our studio ID a
space is a place for a group of people
to organize and collaborate on work in
addition to a personal workspace that
everyone gets automatically you can also
create spaces with roles and permissions
to control project sharing and
visibility for space members so not
coincidentally these spaces work well
for courses sections and workshops
spaces have four different possible
rules the creator of a space is
automatically assigned the admin role
this role is recommended for instructors
admins have total control over the space
and can see unedited it next we have
moderators this work this world works
well for TAS if you have them like an
admin a moderator can see and edit all
projects in a space regardless of
visibility so more on that in just a
minute the contributor role is a good
choice for students contributors could
create new projects in this space and
viewers can see the space but they can't
create new projects in it so this role
could work well for someone who is
auditing the class for example whether
or not a project can be seen by someone
else is controlled by its visibility a
project can be public that is shared
with everyone or private private
projects in a space can be viewed by the
author and also the admins and
moderators of the space private projects
are indicated with a lock icon like that
ok so let's take a look at what this
might look like in practice this is a
space that I've created for that intro
today in a science class that I'm
teaching this semester since I've
created this space my role is admin
which is great because I'm an instructor
and here I'm on the project listing page
this project this space is a few
projects and it already all of these
have been created by me
I can create more new projects here uh
via this menu so to get my class started
let's first take a look at how to add
students to this space I'm gonna click
on this members tab here and here I'd
see a list of all the members of this
space but right now it's just me and my
TA hobby
um here I can invite new members and set
their roles I could add my students to
the space one by one by clicking this
button and typing in their email
addresses this kind of takes a little
while the the easiest way to do this
especially if your class is pretty big
is to make your students share or make
your space shared and let your students
join on their own so in order to do this
I'm gonna click on this shared radio
option over here I don't know if you
guys in the back and see that hopefully
and set the initial role by default the
initial roles contributor which again is
great for students and a little later on
in this semester once everyone has had a
chance to join I can come back in and
set this to invite only and I can always
add people one by one here again so now
that my space is shared I'm gonna copy
the link that it generates and I can
send it out and anyone following that
link will automatically join my space
before I send this link to my students
though there are a couple of other
permissions I might want to consider
here the first one that's the most
important to me is this one right here
in the middle contributors can make
their projects visible to all members
so this setting controls whether
contributors can share their projects
with everyone that is make them public
to the space if you're using your space
for homework or exams or any other
situation where your students work
shouldn't be viewed by other students
you might want to make sure this setting
is unchecked I'm gonna do that now for
my class the other two check boxes here
control whether or not contributors and
viewers can see the members list by
default they can which is fine by me
okay so I'm gonna go back to the
projects listing that we saw initially
by clicking on this project stop here so
all projects in a space like this one
are not shared by default this is great
for me because it means my students
won't be able to see each other's work
however this also means that as an
instructor I need to make sure that any
projects I want my students to open have
been shared by shared with everyone so I
can tell if a project is private the end
has not been shared by the lock icon
next to it like this one to make sure
that I'm sharing the projects I want my
students to see I can filter this list
to only see the public projects via the
shared with everyone option here
now that I've done that I can see the
list of my shared projects is much
smaller and I'm noticing that my example
to project is not in this list so this
means that my students will not be able
to open it I'm gonna go back to the
listing by all and I will open example
two to see what's going on right here
okay so this project is loading but I
can actually do this now I'm gonna open
this gear menu here and click on this
access tab and I can see that it's only
visible by me so I'm gonna switch this
to everyone and stat 101 right there
okay now if I go back to the listing it
doesn't have the lock icon next to it
and if I go back to shared with everyone
it shows up there too okay
so I'm gonna flip back to all projects
real quick okay so now if you're
creating projects that you want your
students to start from and complete like
homework or exams for example you want
them to have their own copy of the
project to work on this is where
assignment assignments come in so
basically anyone opening an assignment
project will automatically get their own
safe copy of it this is great because it
means my students won't have to remember
to make a copy themselves and they will
always come back to any work that
they've started so looking at this list
of some of these projects look a little
different from the other ones I'm going
to scroll down here so these two
homework projects both have an
assignment label hopefully you can read
that it's the big gray box here says
assignment but this one down here
doesn't so I'm going to open it up it
also has a lock icon it hasn't been
shared yet so I'm going to put it up and
see what's inside
so this is a homework assignment that I
was still riding up I hadn't shared it
yet but I'm done with it now and it's
ready for my students to start so once
it opens actually while it's opening I
can do this I'm gonna rename it so I'll
take out the work in progress of the
part this is on our markdown so I'm
gonna rename it we all know okay and I'm
gonna make it into an assignment so I do
that over here again in this gear menu
and I click on this access tab and first
I need to share it with the space and
then I can click here to make the
project and do an assignment okay so I'm
gonna leave that for now and I'm gonna
switch views to see what it might look
like to be a student in this course so
I'm gonna switch over here here I've
logged in as another user my name is Mel
the student you hopefully keep us
straight and I'm gonna join the space
for you the link we copied a little bit
ago
okay so when I follow that link and join
the space I'm going to see a welcome
message here and if I click on the
project's tab I'll see the project's
listing for this space so as this
student my view looks a little bit
different right now I'm only seeing the
the project's in this space that the
instructor has created and shared so
first I'm going to take an example a
look at example number one from the
students point of view because this
project is not an assignment if I open
it up I'm gonna get some what's called a
temporary copy so in general when you
create a cup I'm sorry when in general
when you open a project that's been
created by someone else you get a
temporary copy of that project you can
play around with it but any changes made
to a temporary copy will not be
persisted unless you take an explicit
action to save them so this is great for
say example projects if you want your
students to see or run some code on a
one-off kind of a way so now that I've
it's loaded I can see that it is indeed
a temporary copy due to this big red
temporary indicator here and I can see
also see all of the packages and files
in this project and I can play around so
I'm gonna start here and I'm just gonna
run this code awesome cool okay and I
can make a change here so maybe
and save it okay so this looks like it's
safe but it's still a temporary copy so
if I close this and go back to my
projects listing it's gonna get lost if
I want to save what I'm doing here and
pick it back up later I can click Save
or pay temporary save a permanent copy
and it's pretty fast my changes are
still here everything I've done is
persisted and if I go back over here to
the projects listing
there's my copy so I can come back to it
again so that's great
okay so let's compare that with an
assignment project from a student's
perspective so notice this is a little
bit different from the instructors point
of view if I scroll down here these
labels are blue to begin with and the
the word in here says start
this means that I haven't started any
work on these so I'm going to open
homework number 3 since this project is
an assignment and we'll get a permanent
copy created for me automatically so
this also the next time I open it I'm
gonna come back to any changes that I've
made along the way I don't have to
remember to save a permanent copy it's
already done
since I'm sorry so it's worth noting
here that once someone makes a permanent
copy of any project either directly or
automatically via opening an assignment
like this any changes to the original
will not be reflected in the copies so
it's a good reason as an instructor to
keep your projects private until they're
ready for students did you work on them
so now that my project is open I can see
that there's no temporary indicator here
so this is my copy I can make some
changes here I'm gonna click on start
here like oh there's a lot of stuff in
here
let's see help and save it okay so let
me go back to the listing here and I can
see that this label has actually changed
to continue alright so I'm gonna switch
back over to the instructors point of
view we'll leave we'll leave the student
to her work and I'm gonna jump quickly
into the members view and I can see that
Mel the student has joined okay so I'm
gonna go back to the project the project
view here I've mentioned before that
admins and moderators can view and edit
all projects in this space this means
that I can open a student's project
directly and see what's going on in
there so let's see this in action again
this is my instructors view and if I
scroll down a little bit here's my
student copy of the assignment create
copies are also grouped under the
original project like this
so having students create copies of your
projects can be a handy way to find them
all again later so I'm gonna click on my
product my students project here and
open it up being able to open a
student's project like this can be very
useful to help them work through bug in
their code particularly if they're
having a hard time describing what the
problem is like they just write help an
important note here so opening a
students project like this does not give
me a temporary copy like there's no
there's no temporary indicator up here
this is actually her mellow students
project so I can see the changes that
she's made and this means that I can
also make changes here but I'm making
changes in her project so this is
powerful but but please be careful okay
so I'm gonna leave this for a sec and
time travel a bit to the end of the
semester
I've actually been teaching two courses
stat 101 and stat 204 and I'm gonna open
up the space force tattoo before I take
a look at it
okay so this is a little bit more going
on in here and I have a members list
these are all of my students and so if I
go back off back to here to projects
well our studio cloud makes it easy to
do a lot of this like heavy lifting this
actually represents a fair bit of work
for me
and I'd like to use it again next
semester and I can actually do that
right here so I can copy this space up
here in this menu copy space this brings
up a dialog and I'm gonna rename my new
space here this is for the spring or
time-traveling fun
okay so copying this space in this way
that was really fast it copies all of my
public projects none of the members are
included but that's fine because I'm
probably gonna have a completely
different way but it gives me a really
good jumping-off point for next
semester's coursework from here I can go
in and set any projects I don't want my
students seeing yet to be private or do
anything else I need to do before
letting them in so this can be really
handy to save time recreating all these
projects for the next semester I can
also delete a space to keep this clean
via the same menu up here like this
okay I'm gonna pivot away from my
classes just a bit and talk about some
other learning resources available in
our studio cloud so you can check these
out at our studio dot cloud slash learn
they're also available on the Left nav
here under your list of spaces the first
thing I want to touch on is primers that
Carl talked about two primers are
interactive sets of tutorials that teach
various concepts so I'm gonna open this
one and bring up the visualization
basics and get through it and it's
prompting me you can interact with it
awesome and learning this brings up an
interactive console here that I can
actually type code into and run it so if
I type that G which is what it wants me
to type and run the code I can see the
results and if I mess it up
I get an error message so that's really
cool there are a number of primers here
teaching all sorts of things and these
can act as supplementary material for a
class for example anyone can use these
right now and they've been built using a
package called learn R you can learn
more about it down here so in the same
section we have a link to the guide to
tell you about how to use our studio
cloud if I'm going too fast here have a
collection of data camp courses using
our our downloadable cheat sheets all
right in here and a section on what's
new in our studio cloud this is a good
one to pay attention it will highlight
big new changes in here okay so back to
slides okay so the workflow that I just
described makes good use of copy
projects via assignments however you
might want your students to create new
projects themselves if they're pulling
code from an existing existing git
repository for example the new project
menu has an option for that
get is really crate this option will
bring up a dialog to enter enter a
repository URL and our studio cloud will
create a new project for it once the
project is created you may have to log
in but once you do you'll have all of
your source room get right there one
final helpful thing you can set up your
space such that all new projects created
in it will include a default set of
packages and files this is done by
selecting a based project in this space
settings you can actually take advantage
of this feature when creating
assignments for your class if your
assignments all need the same set of
packages say you want the tidy verse in
all of them you can create a project in
your space with those packages installed
and set it as the base project all new
projects will have those packages
installed automatically note that base
projects are not retroactive and won't
be a won't apply to previously created
projects and you can learn more about
this in the guide I'm sorry to tease a
tantalising bit of setup like this but
I'm really short on time so our studio
cloud as it currently has a few limits
to be aware of our studio cloud is still
an alpha product we do not currently
support simultaneous collaborative at a
if your students need to collaborate on
work in this way we suggest using a git
based repository for code using source
control is not a terrible idea
regardless currently projects are
limited to one gig of ram and by default
you can create one additional private
space with up to 10 members and 25
projects if you need extra spaces or
extra capacity please reach out to us
particularly if you want to use our
Studio Club for teaching and we will do
our best to accommodate you you can see
a capacity message on the projects and
members listing page if you hit that
point and you can request more capacity
via the button there so some best
practices in summary first use our
studio cloud for teaching I am biased
but I think it's really great second use
spaces to get the helpful features that
we've just talked about like assignments
which takes me to third make use of
assignments and spaces this will make
sure that your students do not
inadvertently lose work because they
forgot to create a permanent copy also
because only public projects can be
assignments this ensures that your
students will have access to the project
you intended to share with them third
take advantage of space rules and
permissions to make sure students can
only see what they should and finally
test things out ahead of time make sure
you're not gonna hit RAM limits and that
you have the capacity that you need so I
want to briefly mention that while I've
talked a lot about teaching in this talk
our studio cloud can be used for other
situations too if you want to use it to
share your analyses for example please
do come and take it for a spin you can
create projects in your personal
workspace and share them with others and
while the memory limits apply to all
projects the project capacity limit is
much higher in your workspace by default
and unlike in spaces shared projects
created in your workspace can be seen by
anyone with a project URL in our studio
cloud account so they're a little easier
to share out you can learn more about
that in the guide so we are actively
releasing new features all the time
please keep an eye out on the what's new
section and we'll highlight big changes
there but also know in addition to the
big stuff we roll out small improvements
often if you have questions or feedback
will use our studio cloud please reach
out to us on community via the dedicated
our Studio cloud category we're pretty
active there and we'd love to know what
you think also feel free to come find me
during a little remaining time in the
conference I'd love to talk to you about
our studio cloud we hope that our studio
cloud makes your teaching and learning
lives easier
I see a question over on the far side
and then a couple a couple more um if
you're interested in going off to the
break don't worry about it but we'll
keep going with questions if you're okay
yeah hi that was great thank you I saw
when you were setting some of the
permissions in order to get something
flagged as an assignment it had to be
available to everyone yes but at that
point can it still be locked so if I
wanted to create like 20 assignments
before the semester starts and then over
the course of semester begin to release
them to students no in order to hit to
get the the option to set something in
an assignment it has to be public so so
you just create a whole bunch of
projects and as you go yeah me flag is
assignment yeah I had marked as like
work in progress I think you know find
some way to label them and then you can
come back to them as you need to release
them and just do both and since they're
in the same spot just doing both at the
same time yeah I thought sorry what
would you begin Lisa okay I think I saw
you first and then we'll we'll circle
back around thank you
I'm just wondering if there's a an easy
way for the students to like download
all the RMD files at the end of the
course cuz that's one thing I've
struggled with with using our studio
server yeah I feel like they're attached
to this earth I think you can export
everything perfect yeah thank you okay
hello is it easy to share data files
with students I think it depends on so
if you wanted all your students to have
like a data file and say a project or
something like that you could create a
project and then they could all make a
copy of it or if said an assignment they
all open it they'll get their own copies
is that is that kind of what you mean
yeah or maybe if it's a larger file just
one file and then every student can
access to the same file because for a
deep learning model that could take 500
megabyte yeah so um datasets or
something that's on our long-term plan
but we don't have that right now but
maybe come talk to me afterwards okay
which doesn't work it doesn't Oh is
there a feature in assignments that lets
them have a deadline a closing time when
students can't work on them anymore huh
not yet yeah that's that's hide our list
that is a good call wait hello yes I was
wondering if there's a way to let's say
break your class into groups of four and
have it said they could see each other's
work but not the other groups yeah we
don't currently support that probably
the best way to do that would be to
maybe push your code to to get and pull
the everybody pull the same code down
and create four separate projects we
don't have a like groups or anything
like that yet it's something we're
considering any high weight
keep speaking I'm wondering if Asura is
there a way for students to knit our
markdown documents okay cool and is
there a way of like do how do you grade
your assignments in your course do you
grade them through this we don't have a
mechanism for that you can open up all
other students and see are all of their
projects and see it but we don't have a
way to feed that back in through this
yeah yeah so external new using this in
a like a lab type setting yeah can we
just make everybody admins and admins
but sure everybody can be editing
everybody else's and working together
yeah so um an admin can delete the space
so I wouldn't necessarily make everyone
an admin a moderator would probably work
for that if you have we don't support
the simultaneous collaborative editing
so once you do that you're actually
taking over the project so you can't
just like willy-nilly do that so I'm
saying like be careful with it but you
could definitely make everybody
moderators if you want to sure
[Music]